okay at 4:00 time he's 1919-20 okay
maybe I'll play let's play a fun game
it's clear from z5 what oh.he preme of
that d6 okay Knight f3 Knight f3 Oh g v
g5 let's go
so it's a bit faster than normal I still
listen carefully man g5 on move 3d 4d 4
oh that's a good move I think I can play
g4 here
g4 there we go Knight ft 2 like f d2 now
I can take on e5 d65 also thanks for
subbing I probably would I don't really
need it to go this fast but it's too
late now
alright so we have a really weird
position White has double pawns and
neither on f9 on D - I'm feeling pretty
content there's an interesting trap
actually the play Bishop c5 Bishop c5
hoping for a knight p3s white might play
94 good night he fell okay I'm ready to
trade Queen's of Knight c3 c3 now I just
want to play Queen d4 inmate but Quincy
for there's 94 mm Lieb is about five
fish about five efore
a little bit conflicted here I think
I'll just plain late c64 396 knight c6
94 all probably just played Bishop b 6y
g 3g three interesting wait isn't there
a pawn on e5 there is night 685
okay so materials equal Bishop g2 now I
have Queen I still want to play Queen d4
if it doesn't quite work wait did I
already played this by five right now
I'm forgetting while they played Knight
sexy g3 knight c6 Knight c3 Bishop c5 I
never played this right okay
Bishop g2 so Bishop g2 what's the play
Queen e7 Queen e7 I'm fantasizing about
it like 9 f3 check white 2 minutes 28
seconds black 1 minute 6 seconds to move
faster not de 494 Bishop Bishop e6 ok so
I want to play a 5 probably and white
can't castle which is nice so what make
me threatening Bishop g5 95
Oh oh that's a good move yes I have 26
Queen e6p moving actually if Knight
takes c6 I I think I'll take back with a
queen just to keep white from castling
Bishop e3 e3 let's just take it
Bishop 63 love than you look oh thanks
Knights Dixie 7 check oh my queen but
actually my queen can you give me 7 okay
kind of I should treat this like a
gambit it's tapered Bishop Bishop 66
sorry though
I have everything on the e-file
basically where's whites night still on
seat no not on c3 funny for I've seen
like hallucinations it's not good I have
a sense of where most of the pieces are
but sadly my queen is off the board
c3 now the Queen wants to develop
let's play time f5
I thought there's another need for not
sure though not a - ok so there was um I
am Brooke da de yes wait
oh my Knights on g2 Queen a 406 Knight
f6
okay so just developing or my Bishop
defends e7 that's nice
oh thanks for something so there's kind
of some conversation kingside castles
huh you had no more how can you happen
huh let's play h5h why don't practice
too much I don't want to get AB literate
greetings Mac clean before oh hey max
how's it going Queen B for Chuck this is
just warm up kind of chaos King f7o be
seventh-inning
but then rook d7 Queen snakes b7 check
rookie 7 I know there's three second
increments
that's an interesting position I have
all my minor pieces Knights on e5 f6
bishops on e 63 not enough twos pinned
Queen B full Queen before he'll stage
for wife a chole there we go
all my pieces were working together
hmm
white zero minutes twenty six seven
G snakes h4 Brooks takes Rick 81
edu one just say let's play rookies
seven lucky seven just being safe I
think I want to play f4 g3
it's a wild position but the eight
rookie it therefore for Rick everyone do
you g 3h 63 I'm cheaper at the g3 g3 go
Queen snakes h4 o my rook da two bishops
takes up to check and then night Thank
You g4 90 G for it's almost meat like
wait wait is there pot there's no colony
to is there bishop a3 Bishop f3 92 93
checkmate oh it's meat there's a pony -
oh it's meat
oh haha it's appalling you - I assumed I
forgot I would have thought it moved I
was trying to calculate this and then
this but okay let's close it 93
checkmate this night helps keep the king
safe avoiding stopping checks and thanks
for the game kinder kinder homonym I was
um it was actually probably good choice
increasing the speed of the voice
because it saved it probably save some
like split seconds yeah uh I checked I
mean let me turn off the thing let's
turn the volume and let's quickly
quickly see what happened I mean this is
this is a crazy line objectively this
should be good for white in some way
I was feeling good here and then I I
completely I mean I saw I saw the fact
my bishop was defending this a previous
position but then escaped my mind but it
was still interesting and I guess the
pawn never moved
i I just this I was completely blind to
this thankfully like the Knights
something like save the day
and this is actually this is nice
because if the pawn moves I can play
Bishop c4 first and OGG yeah I mean
definitely you're definitely better at
various points
I was probably you to birdie so people
on YouTube watching in the future hope
you enjoyed that thanks for watching